نضيف كل أسبوع حوالي
1.3 مليون شخص حول العالم إلى
المدن والبلدات، فمن ناحية نعلم
أن المدن تتسم بالكفاءة بشكل لا يصدق ولكن من ناحية أخرى
نعلم أن
المناطق الحضرية تساهم في حوالي ثلاثة أرباع
انبعاثات غازات الدفيئة على مستوى العالم،
وليس كل شيء  المدينة متساوية في تأثيرها
ولكن كل مدينة تحتاج إلى أن تكون جزءًا من
الحل
حتى تتمكن كل مدينة من نشر ثلاث
مجموعات كبيرة من الحلول للمساعدة في حل
تغير المناخ،
واحدة
يمكنها تقليل الطلب الحضري على الطاقة
والمواد ويمكنها القيام بذلك عن طريق
تصميم المدن  والأحياء بحيث
يكون الناس على مقربة من المرافق
التي يرغبون في الوصول إليها، على سبيل
المثال، يمكننا تقليل استخدام الطاقة إذا
وضعنا السكن بالقرب من أماكن
الأنشطة التجارية بحيث لا يضطر الناس إلى
القيادة بعيدًا أو حتى أفضل إذا كانوا
يمكنك حتى المشي جزءًا مما
يشتريه لك الموقع المشترك أيضًا، هل هذه المنازل تميل إلى أن تكون
أصغر حجمًا، فكر في الشقق التي لدينا
ميزة الجدران المشتركة، فهي لا
تشغل مساحة كبيرة من الأرض، ولا تستهلك
الكثير من المواد،
وبعض من أشهرها  الوجهات السياحية في المدينة
في جميع أنحاء العالم تميل
إلى أن تكون جيدة للمشي وذلك
لأن الإسكان مختلط
بالمساحات التجارية والشيء
الثاني الذي يمكن لكل مدينة
القيام به هو التحول إلى مصادر طاقة منخفضة الكربون أو صافية
صفر، وهذا يعني
كهربة نظام الطاقة الحضري ولكن
كما أن استخدام مصادر طاقة منخفضة الكربون أو صافي الصفر
لإنشاء
جزء من الكهرباء يعمل أيضًا على كهربة
التنقل والسيارات ولكنه أيضًا يعمل على كهربة
أسطول الحافلات
وأسطول الطوارئ البلدي، كل شيء
مثال رائع هو دنفر، كولورادو، حفزت دنفر
الشركات والمقيمين على
التحول إلى  الكهرباء منخفضة الكربون،
الشيء الثالث الذي يمكن لكل مدينة القيام به
هو زيادة تخزين الكربون
واستيعابه، ونعني بذلك زيادة
الغطاء النباتي في المدن حتى
تتمكن النباتات من إخراج الكربون من
الغلاف الجوي ولكن أحد أكثر
الأشياء قيمة حول الغطاء النباتي الحضري
والمساحات الخضراء خاصة الأشجار الحضرية هي
تأثير التبريد الذي تتمتع به الأشجار والتي
تخدم العديد من الأغراض المختلفة بما في ذلك
المزيد من الظل مما يقلل من استخدام الطاقة في المبنى.
تعتبر نيو هافن مثالًا رائعًا لمدينة
زادت بشكل كبير من
المساحة الخضراء الحضرية التي يطلب سكانها إنشاء
مجتمعات مجاورة مليئة بالأشجار في الشوارع.
ونجتمع معًا ونطلب ذلك،
وأنا واثق جدًا من أن المدن يمكنها الارتقاء
إلى مستوى التحدي، وببساطة لأنه
يتعين عليها ذلك، أعني أن المدن تغمرها
تأثيرات تغير المناخ كل يوم، ومن
المؤكد أن نافذة الفرص
تنغلق ولكن يمكننا جميعًا أن نفعل شيئًا ما
الآن كمجتمعات ولكن أيضًا
كمدن
[موسيقى]